all right a quick game of one to ten how
big of a loss if the player can't play
and there's the nfc bracket and on
sunday afternoon in the middle game
you've got the saints hosting the bears
alvin kamara eligible to play on sunday
sean payton tight-lipped on monday
whether or not camaro would play because
he can't practice he can't be back with
the team until sunday the day of the
game so scale of 1-10 how big of a loss
if alvin kamara due to his positive
covet 19 test result from last week if
he can't play how big a loss well all
right so tens being the the like the the
heart like yes yeah typically yes yes
yes one to ten being the biggest amazing
as alvin kamara is for this game itself
and everything the bears defense which
has not been real dominant lately i'm
only gonna i'm gonna put it at like a
six
uh as far as how i mean he's important
but if they as long as they have
latavius murray you know they'll be okay
that's why i'll say that
mike evans the buccaneers receiver mri
showed no structural damage to the knee
he's day to day one to ten how big of a
loss if he can't play on saturday night
at water well i mean we know what a
study is right we both do but again i
would say in this particular match up
with washington and everything like that
they still got antonio brown and
gronkowski and they're playing a team
that's offensively challenged
i i think again i don't think it's going
to be like oh no they're going to have
to be a totally different team they'll
be fine in this particular matchup so
i'll i'll put that at a 6-2 mike
buccaneers linebacker devon white won't
play because of his covet 19 test result
bruce aryan's not happy that they were
playing saturday because he could have
played on sunday what's his impact one
to ten well he's he's awesome he flies
around the football field i mean he's
sidelined to sideline the physical
specimen awesome and all that but you
know it's the same as i said but the
other two a little here where i just go
okay this washington offense not real
special antonio gibson not totally
normal at running back still dealing
with turf toe all of that so they can
deal and they got levante david there in
the middle i'll put this one yeah i'm
gonna again i'm gonna go to five here i
think it's it's manageable they won't be
like a totally different defense without
devon white it'll hurt but they won't be
done
jamal adams the seahawks safety he
exited the week 17 game with a shoulder
injury his availability for the game
against the rams is in question one to
ten nine i this is this one's big you
got the rams the bootlegs and all of
that stuff the run game you know he's
he's the eraser so that's one that
concerns me more than any other one
we've said so far with jamal adams
one more quick one olivier vernon he is
done with a ruptured achilles tendon
huge rounds huge the steelers are gonna
throw at every play you need a pass rush
so that's like an eight or a nine again
two to lose him and this matchup is big
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports